thank you
[Music]
good news for Colleen Kia and Hyundai
have just agreed to settle a class
action loss we did it guys
well done gentlemen well done well done
all right so there yeah 200 with the
money dude 200 million over the claims
at their cars the claims unsubstantiated
yeah that the cars are easy to steal I
don't know about that are they
case improving good yeah seven minutes
are you able to join this class action
lawsuit
um from the article that I was sent by
my mother it seems like
it is
just a proposal meaning it will be it
needs to be improved by the court before
consumers can begin to file for
reimbursements okay waiting on that yeah
okay but yeah for those who don't know
Colleen had a Kia it was stolen
um
yeah it was the personal best for those
two thieves and uh we're getting really
good at this which is really good I
think it's really good timing because
they've been getting stolen for so
freaking long and then right when yours
gets stolen then they decide to go okay
Colleen's pushed it over the edge we
need to get this lawsuit
in Milwaukee I think it's been going on
for like two years before them like
actually trying to do something about it
and then it hit here for a while
um but yeah I mean I remember going to
the police station and telling the cop
hey my car got stolen I need to file a
report yeah and he just looked at me
he's like what car is it I was like it's
a Kia yep he just like opens his drawer
and pulls out a USB he's like this is
all they need and I was like oh
yeah
like all right cool can I file that
paperwork now all right thanks for
telling me yeah wait do you think that
makes it easier to steal than a like a
Honda Civic or something like that
because that used to be like the number
one car that was stolen right I think it
does because like the crazy thing is
like I didn't I never knew that in our
lifetime we would see a car that is
going viral for being stolen that's
pretty cool like in our day like yeah
Camry's it was like common sense that
you can steal camera and Ultima pretty
easily or a Honda but it wasn't to this
degree where people were making videos
and someone's doing it why and he was
getting abused like and then people
there was hashtags for it for the dudes
that would be stealing it it's like this
is another level like they don't do
something about this that's ridiculous
like they gotta do something right you
know the cops are saying they're like
can't stop the internet
they're also the ones yeah you know the
news stations saying hey so this has
been happening and this is how it's
being done yeah it's just like it just
adds to it which is strange because when
you have so many recalls for so many
cars like you know it's it's like that
thing where if there's no incentive for
the car company to protect themselves
from a lawsuit they're not gonna act
correct yeah this is like a pretty good
example it took them a long time to
really like go pick up he and Hyundai
they're Korean right
here technically it's not Hyundai it's
it's Hyundai Hyundai you know whatever
man you correct everybody
Chinese people
speaking as a resident Korean expert
yeah you do this on purpose yeah what's
your guys's deal so
um right now what is the most searched
Car Company online Tesla I would say
probably Kia Hyundai right now because
of this okay so isn't any marketing good
marketing wow
because you know you know the number one
car uh sales company is Toyota like my
fault like no one comes close right yeah
but when when Hyundai did get close is
when Prius had that problem
when priest was allegedly like just kept
going they wouldn't stop I don't like
that you're making sense here man so the
sales went down a little bit they were
still number one but because they got
caught up uh they they were really close
but then everyone knows one saw that
news blows over Toyota went right back
to the top where they were so Hyundai
they've got people that are you know
assuming they're they're really smart
they know this is going to blow over 200
215 250 million dollars cool whatever
once it all blows over
hey and then there's reports oh they got
it fixed everything's good now yeah go
ahead they go you know what to
incentivize and what Kevin did with that
was really smart back then was they they
were the first 10-year 100 000 mile
warranty oh the people that are into
that they're like oh this is great let's
do this they'll probably do something
like that again and then they'll sell us
a ticket
yeah I'm not saying it was planned but
it's it's more like lemonade out of
lemons you know what they're gonna do
yeah
the makers of it they're gonna be like
let's just take the USB port out
[Laughter]
could you imagine getting that email
like hey like oh so it's the USB port so
just put a couple yeah
sugar make sure all the sugar
so it's extra sticky they can be real
stupid lately
you're the one that said you could steal
the car with a USB yeah that's correct
but you don't put it through the port
then where do you put a clinch
ERS
and because the USB fits so perfectly
with the key condition that's how people
are starting in the car 10 more cars are
gonna get stolen because of this video
but then there's a smaller piece of the
pie for you you know what would be
really great is if if his thing is
correct where it is on purpose that they
did this and then freaking Daewoo goes
let's just make a girl that doesn't even
have a key
you can just take it and it'll let
people in six years
dude that'd be so sick imagine and
there's no other car that has a cooler
name and then they send like these like
fake dudes to like stand by the daewoo's
and like so you guys want to take this
thing
there's no keys
anybody can steal this car at any time
you just need a normal hand oh no
[Laughter]
but that'd be so great if someone
misinterpreted to that degree to just be
stealable as a marketing tactic yeah is
that a thing I'm sure I'm sure you know
it's the Rebrand people love uh I come
from behind stories they do love that
they're like what's worse though okay a
car that can get easily stolen or a car
that is love number one by terrorists
like the Tacoma Toyota yeah yeah
all the soldiers are in uh Toyota Tacoma
yeah mid-level management are in
forerunners and then like upper
management are Land Cruisers same in the
cartel too bro yeah
all of them Drive Land Cruisers
know you want it to be reliable exactly
yeah right and then so Florida says oh
we don't know anything about it but I'm
sorry but all car companies they know
exactly where all they're called they
know they know exactly yeah but then
that just makes Toyota look better
because it's like anything by the
reliable car yeah that doesn't make you
look better
they don't say that though because they
can't but they know they know exactly
where they're called imagine if like
they you know the old 80s Toyota Hilux
what if they were shipping those to the
um those specific countries already with
the bolt holes to put the mountable
machine gun right yeah and that's
convenience for the buyer right
there's like Hyundai Elantra with no
touch screen it's a basal launcher
because some countries they won't they
can't afford they don't they can't
afford the touchscreen like the base
part of the touchscreen so they offer
one without a touchscreen if you look it
up how much cheaper it is but if you
look it up um if they show a photo and
so where the touchscreen would be it's
just like some random place the knobs
right yeah it's like yeah
it's really weird am I in the car yeah
it's like it's a check yourself
look to look at themselves what they
look like when they're shooting
it's for them to go what have I become
it's like it's your last chance to like
change your life
the mirror down oh my God look at me
sorry sweaters
they're making like um available options
right for certain yeah well because you
know each country have they have their
own like demographics or environments or
whatnot yeah I mean these are
multi-billion dollar companies yeah I
thought you were gonna say they took the
touching out because it was like
sacrilegious to some uh cultures oh you
can't touch this that'd be a better
reason
um well congratulate me once I actually
get the funds you're gonna get it
what kind of hit
if I get the upwards to
6125 that's the most that's the cap yeah
the conversation for the total loss of
the vehicle ranges up to it's such a
specific number I wonder how they
calculated that
um
6125 and compensation for damage to cars
and personal property that ranges up to
3375.
um
car brands will also be compensating
owners for travel expenses resulting
from theft like car rental fees public
transportation reimbursement order
profit tickets
Etc exactly all those receipts I got all
the receipts what about the emotional
distress
um yeah
they're like send us the selfie videos
of you crying yeah
I can't really happen
ing yeah it looks legit
um
the JK news video yeah that'll be a part
of yeah
the next meeting the next OTR we do is
going to be sponsored by Hyundai
thank you